la nuit prochaine à 2 heures du matin il
sera 3 heures ce 29 mars ne durera que
23 heures au lieu de 24
une heure de confinement hommes c'est
toujours bon à prendre mais pourquoi les
jours sont-ils découper un 24 heures
cette division remonte aux babyloniens
une civilisation qui s'est épanouie 2000
ans avant jésus-christ au moyen-orient
les babyloniens comptait sur quatre
doigts avec le pouce et comme nous avons
trois phalange 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 x 2 ça fait 24 12
c'est très pratique on peut le diviser
par 2 par 3 par 4 par 6 alors que 10
seulement par 2 et par cinq les
babyloniens avait aussi observé que
l'année dur grosso modo 360 jours un
multiple de 12 ils ont donc divisé
l'année en 12 mois leur en 60 minutes
la minute en 60 secondes une minute
c'est la durée d'une capsule de déconfit
n'est allé à demain et n'oubliez pas
nous sommes confinés
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain